you
hi everyone welcome to the backstage for
them making apps beautiful series we're
actually going to be doing to backstage
episodes so they're based on the android
dev bytes making apps beautiful so so
far we've had parts 1 2 & 3 available
and here's your opportunity to join us
and ask questions so to get started I'm
Ankur Kotwal and I'm a developer
advocate here in the Sydney office yeah
and I'm young flesh market I'm an
Android develop programs engineer also
here in Sydney obviously so we tried
doing this once before and so hopefully
we're all going to be good to go today
so thanks for joining us we have a
number of questions that have been
submitted before the event started but
we also have a number of people joining
us live yeah that's right so if you have
a question the hang out and just just
ping us wrestling the chat and we will
put you up and you can ask your question
life but to get started let's go to one
of our first questions we received an
hour plus page before and this question
is coming from Hannah's Dorfman and he's
asking about transparent action bars so
if I make an action bar transparent
through the content of a component that
has match parent height for instance the
main activity layout set with
setcontentview automatically be
stretched invisible underneath the
action bar and do you think it's
generally a good idea focusable like
we're doing it in the Google Play Music
app and the Grand Street in the Green
Street so let's split this question up
into two the first is about getting an
action bar that actually floats above
your content the way you do that is
actually by specifying and an XML
attribute in your layouts called action
bar window overlay so if you set this
basically what it will do is put the
action bar on top and the content behind
it with with that content behind it then
that what that means is that you can
take advantages and advantage of things
like the transparent action bar so for
example Google music we use that
transparent action bar to show you the
the imagery for the artist or the album
so what happens is when you
you when you see the artist to start
with the transparent by the action bar
starts off transparent and then as you
scroll it becomes more opaque that's a
really nice effect because what it does
is it actually helps to retain the the
visual branding that we're trying to get
with that orange color of the the Play
Music app but we're also trying to give
away that screen real estate for that
rich media so as we're at the very top
you can see it and then as you scroll it
sort of becomes opaque over time so it's
a really nice effect so then you think
it would make sense to include this in
your application I think it's typically
where you need real estate back so
you've got a decent amount of content
that you kind of you know you want to
take up that space so that that action
bar might be using and in particular
it's actually when you have rich media
like images so we have this this artist
profile here so in play music now grand
street is interesting because they use
the transparent action bus throughout
and again what they're doing is they're
they're sort of taking away the chrome
or the the UI elements so they're
actually what they do is that you'll see
that around their buttons in the action
bus or their action items they've got
some sort of translucent borders but the
main section of the action bar because
they're not actually displaying anything
they're choosing to make that
transparent and I mean the question was
do you like the general idea to be
honest this is more of a design question
and it depends on your design if you're
trying to really showcase those
beautiful images that you may have may
or may not have in your app then
attracts transparent action bar makes
sense but if you want to retain that
sort of brand identity then then go
ahead and keep an opaque or opaque color
or an image there yeah okay so our hands
I think his hands had another question
as well saying I saw the Google Play
redesigned video and he was referring to
the Android design in action episode
that we had for that and said I'm a big
car a fan of the card principle and
would like to implement something like
that in my name
that I'm wondering how they achieve an
adapter that works with different card
sizes is it a simple list view that
inflates for instance a horizontal
linear layout that already contains one
big card and to medium cards and for
small cards and he's given us given us
an image there or is it a gridview with
a special view adapter can you implement
can you give any hint on how to
implement something like this well so
rather than focusing them specifically
what that implementation is what I'd be
saying is have a look at what works well
with your code so having a list view
with a linear layout in it is not a bad
idea not a bad way to do it you do you
don't have to use a linear lat you could
use a relative layout and in some ways a
relative layout might be a bit more
flexible for for allowing you to vary
the number of cards so what I'd be doing
is basically my adapter I'd be keeping
track of do I need to present this as a
big card or well if you have three sizes
a small medium large and then
dynamically try and set the proportions
accordingly so we don't currently have
any real sample code there that shows
users how to developers how to do this
but you can envisage that if you're
dynamically loading these creating these
views it shouldn't be too hard once you
know your heuristic to work out with
what size the card should be you can
easily just kind of say hey I want it to
be you know double the size of this or
not so yeah I mean it's all about
dynamically loading it in okay I hope
that answers your questions Hans now we
have a few people that have joined us on
the Hangout so maybe we'll take this
opportunity to see if we if there were
nonetheless any questions leave a
question from Matthew Mark if you want
to come live on the Hangout or is it
okay if you just read out a question can
do both well I'm not hearing anything so
why don't we just okay mask so so Marty
is asking about any tips on getting the
search working on the action bar I want
to have my user and an address and have
google maps me to search for it and
place a marker IV actually hi Marty we
have you live on there we go
how's it going good you've got glass on
I thought you might join us from glass
yeah that's right yeah okay can't you
there yet so any tips for getting the
search working on the action bar so are
you talking about like a search view
yeah I'm trying to do a search view and
can't get it to can't seem to get to the
work and search in my app so are you
talking about at a presentation level or
are you talking about the integration of
like doing the search operation so the
indexing and the looking up of the
keywords I am adding a search view on
the option menu and I want to have that
just for that particular fragment and
want to have it searched an address on
the map actually all on the map on the
map so you want would you like the map
to kind of pan around as the results
start to show actually what I wanted to
do is if I can get it to search the
address i'm going to have it then put a
marker and then handed that marker got
you got you so can I just ask one one
more question are you looking for sort
of auto complete as well there so I mean
it's an address so people may not be
typing in the whole thing they might be
expecting an order complete um this is
my first shot at Soho that'd be nice but
it's not it you know must have right now
okay so I mean what I'd be looking for
is just using a standard search view
that we have and it's it you've asked
this question at a really good time
because we're about to publish and
documentation around this very shortly
so on best practices on how to integrate
the search for you so I think that will
actually solve your your questions but
was there something specific that we
that was holding that you were being
held back in I just haven't seen a good
example of how to do it so I was out
looking for guidance really okay and you
might also want to look at the geocode
API so you can give it a dress and would
give you a leg long back and it's an API
to Google Maps API so you can look it up
online it's just normal API you can call
you can't take a let long
and then you can just use the normal
Matthew you know at marker and change
the camera on those kind of things list
it's intact yeah I'm able to do that I'm
able to do that right now I'm just not
equal to three in the in that search in
the options menu okay have you had a
look at the creating a searching a face
API guide that we have on
developer.android.com know that I'll go
take a look at them yeah that one goes
through it in a good amount of detail so
I to just start there and if you still
have troubles and join us next time
again exactly being searched in your
face yeah I'll take a look at it pinky
ok no worries thanks for joining us so
is there anyone else that would like to
ask a question on the Hangout if you are
if you are interested in asking a
question please just let us know on the
chat and then we can unmute you and have
you join you up on the screen so in the
meantime we'll move on to the next sort
of yeah question that we had there so so
we've been in the first two three pals
you can talk about making it a beautiful
right and we've been kind of talking
about what a beautiful app really should
be like what makes an appt really
beautiful right so and and you've been
talking about modernizing an app but the
question is how do you spot an on modern
app what is what makes an appt appt not
beautiful these days yeah it's
interesting I'll admit that when I look
at fire up an Android app I'm almost
immediately able to sense whether this
is a modern Apple not and i sat down
when this question came up i said then I
thought well what are the cues that give
it away because it's it's obvious to me
but sometimes if you go into the details
it's harder to kind of specify exactly
what and I actually found that there was
a number of things so firstly it's the
legacy menu button this one's really
really important because there are tons
of phones out there that now have
virtual navigation buttons but in
particular the majority the vast
majority of tablets don't have a
physical menu button they have virtual
buttons so if you're not targeting the
latest SDK or rather if you're not
targeting API
11 and up you're going to start to see
that legacy menu button and often
actually it doesn't most people don't
even put a menu in there because we've
kind of you know when when Android first
came about we had these user interfaces
that were designed around having a menu
that wasn't necessarily visible the
action bar and the action overflowed
basically improved that so that you
could see when you had actions available
to you and in that way it replaced what
the menu button did but in a more
powerful manner because you could choose
what to show give things priority have
it automatically stack or split so that
there were a lot of advantages that came
with that so if I'm seeing a legacy menu
button usually to me that's a sign that
developers aren't keeping up they're not
staying modern and frankly API Elevens
been out for a long long time other
school tasks what's a quick fix what's
the easiest thing you need to get rid of
the menu button actually so we covered
it in Episode one it's that target SDK
version that's what you should be
setting and as we said there that won't
necessarily break backward compatibility
because you have the min SDK version
attribute that you can specify in your
manifest to make sure that you're still
showing up on all the devices so legacy
menu button is the first one the next
one is actually using a non holo theme
and by that we don't mean that every
single app needs to look the same or
have the same hollow colors but you know
when an app is is following the holo
theme right you can you can see the way
text fields are specified then the the
way you get touch feedback there's just
I mean if you're targeting an older
version of Android it's immediately
apparent in the way the dialogues are
styled if you've got that hideous title
bar across the top yeah you know we've
moved with the time so having a modern
using a modern theme is a good thing and
especially if you have an app that
you've tested on something more modern
it's just really easy to specify a
different theme for you know ice cream
sandwich and bath for example any meat
you're getting the whole thing with
dialogues and you know the other input
UI elements as well so it's really easy
to actually you know get off man it's so
obvious so if you get a dialogue that
doesn't look like a whole lotta log it's
just yeah
so so legacy menu button on Halloween
the third one for me is the action bar
so the lack of an action bar tells me
that you're either very you're paying a
lot of attention to detail and you're
you're building a really custom
experience that you feel is better than
the action bar and that's ok that's an
endeavor that we we encourage innovation
is always a good thing but often what I
find is apps that aren't using an action
bar are actually the kind of an old
style app so it breaks that sense of
consistent navigation for your users
because when they use their Android
devices whether it's a phone or a tablet
the apps that ship with the system and
the sort of top apps that tend to get
featured or our popular will tend to use
the Android design guidelines so if
you're not using those guidelines don't
do it because of sheer laziness if
you're going to go against the
guidelines or do something custom do it
because you truly are building an
experience that you that that is
superior to the default one so yeah
three things yeah so the action bar is
an interesting one it always tends to
come up so let's talk about in a bit
more more details so let's say you
already have an established branding
like you know you have some some logos
are using some colors or something how
would you include that with your action
bar because they actually would be at
the top and people tend to put logos
there or something similar and some
other apps yeah i mean the action bar is
more for having a consistent sort of
interaction design we still encourage
you to have your own branding have your
own logos theme it and that's what
really episode one of the dead but
series making apps beautiful was all
about theming it so that it's consistent
with your guidelines it's really
important though that you put in things
like the app icon because it again
allows you to establish your identity
the identity of your app and in
particular you want to start looking at
the differentiation between up and back
because it is it definitely provides a
really nice way to navigate through your
app the last thing I guess I want to
mention is is the navigation bar just
before we finish this question the
navigation drawer that's a
that's a pattern that's been around for
a while which is being formalized sort
of mid 2013 by by us and that's a really
nice pattern for grouping functionality
or top-level menus so when when we talk
about how do you spot them a non modern
app to be honest the old dashboard
pattern is something that's kind of
fallen out of favor and the navigation
drawer is a much better use of of
navigation at least at the top level
then dashboard for many things for
starters you're not restricted to a grid
of 6 or 9 or some arbitrary number ok so
it's a developer how would I go about
adding a navigation drawer to my
application so anything we have that
might help develop usually does so I'm
developing on android com / design if
you look in the navigation drawer
section learning we do we describe what
the navigation drawer should look and
feel like we also talk about why and we
provide sample code so you can just drop
that in and it's backward compatible as
well so you can support from android 2.2
and up i believe ya might be two point
wonderful in my head so just on the the
action bar one of the things that i note
that some of I've seen some apps do is
actually provide a fake action bar and
that is that is something that is it
does give a feeling that something that
you the app is not modern even though
you're trying to be modern by having an
action bar if it's if you can obviously
spot that it's not a real action bar it
actually takes away from the experience
and there's some subtle cues that you
should look at so things like the the
spacing often I'll see that action bars
that are that someone is sort of faking
with a linear layout the height of it
just doesn't seem quite right right you
know we will use those sorts of apps if
you if you look at the the spacing even
horizontally if the fonts it's it's not
quite there action items they don't
quite align quite right and in
particular the one thing that I see
missing in a lot of fake action bars is
the touch feedback
because on an action by that touch
feedback is so crucial you see exactly
what region you've you've you interacted
with so in terms of using action bars
our advices either use actionbarsherlock
which is you know a very popular
community effort and a quality product
and it's three well so just because the
product doesn't mean it's not free or
you know consider also using the
actionbarcompat that's that's coming
soon from us that we announced the last
year at i/o and weary announced this
year died so coming soon but the point
is you have at least you'll soon have at
least two choices right now sherlock is
a great way to go so we've actually
talked a lot about the action bar and I
hope we can start to see the importance
of it at least from a modernizing point
of view let's see if do we have any
questions yet on the Hangout doesn't
doesn't look like it just uh if you've
just joined us on the hanger if you do
want to ask some questions please just
let us know in the chat that I'd like to
ask a question and we'll we'll bring you
into to the to the video feed yeah so
action bars and and you're talking about
touch feedback as well so one
interesting interesting thing that
always comes out of spacing I find
because some of your buttons are too
close together or text there's just too
narrow doesn't look right and I know we
talked a bit about spacing in in our in
our deaf bites um let's talk about that
a bit more so what would be the
recommended spacing if you want to have
more fun to put a button on your screen
for example well the good thing is we've
actually documented this on the Android
design guidelines site and again there's
a section called metrics and grids that
actually tells you all about this but
there's a couple of really sort of key
points that we should get across one is
that if you've got something like a list
you have a minimum of 48 dips so that's
density-independent pixels in height
because we feel that that's a that's a
comfortable sort of patch region but
even within those that 48 dip reason
that you have in the list view item you
want to have some padding within that
for their dip so that you've got roughly
about four depths of
padding above a button for example and
below it so that you don't get two
buttons that are so close to one another
that if a user happens to hit somewhere
in that unknown region they might end up
triggering the wrong event or the wrong
button so you know that metrics in grid
page there's a lot of measurements on
there but the ones that I love to that I
particularly pay attention to is the 48
dip rhythm some of the padding numbers
there around items within list views and
the one that I wish more developers paid
attention to is the 16 dips of padding
on on the sides and the reason for that
is as we hold our sort of devices you
know you kind of hold it with you with
your hand and you'll find that your
fingers may end up sort of interacting
with the screen now if you've got a UI
that that touches just all the way up
against the edge you can end up in a
situation where the user is accidentally
triggering those items when they don't
mean to so having those that spacing on
either side very important how about
yourself I mean do you have any sort of
words of advice there so I find a myth a
tablet layout so even if you don't guess
only have time to implement a full
tablet layout just adding a bit more
spacing on the side making fun to time
you think I really help it goes a long
way so I'm especially because if you
have a long list of textable to scroll
through having a bit more spacing on the
side allows you to hold the tablet in
one hand you can scroll through the list
of the other hand it's a good tip of it
was I think I can give people yeah and
actually to go with that when when
you've got some text on a tablet whether
you've got a multi multi pane layout or
not it's important to know that you kind
of want to have a horizontal scan which
is actually comfortable so what we mean
by that is if you've got text that that
you're presenting don't have it going
from edge to edge have it sort of you
use a certain horizontal scan that that
allows users to go left and right very
quickly through the text even if that
means adding padding on the side and we
did this in bacon reader actually in in
the in part three of this devbyte a
series of making apps beautiful you
looked at that that detailed view that
we had
added this padding on the side so that
that horizontal scan is comfortable it's
all surprising how how little we have to
do to get this working but has a huge
impact on this ability and the actual
design right all right that's exactly so
I speaking of text hmm font now one of
the things we've been talking so far
about measuring our layouts in dips but
fonts have a kind of special metric that
usually is right yeah so f of functions
SP and the the idea is that if um
basically should look at accessibility
and in your Android device settings you
can actually change the font size some
of you might have seen it already so you
can but now it's set to normal have a
percent from but you can make it large
or small if you wanted to do that and if
you stick with the SP measurement it's
actually a relative based on that as
well so if somebody has enabled a highly
fifty percent font size for example you
happen automatically scale up for that
and the text automatically get bigger so
specifying fonts that I space definitely
the way forward yeah it's particularly
useful for accessibility right like in
accessibility settings you can set a
minimum font size and SP basically
acknowledges that and applies it the
other thing that's really important in
fonts and it's one that we haven't
actually covered in this particular
series is localization yeah now a lot of
people think that localization just
means translating strings often that's
not the case often you actually need to
also consider things that might be
culturally insensitive as well in the
content of your of your app often
actually for in most cases that sort of
sensitivity is more towards games then
it then it may be towards just a
standard non game app but it's something
that's worth considering but the big
thing that happens from localization is
when you translate some of these strings
depending on the language you use you
you can end up with much longer strings
and then it's possible I know when we
did Santa tracker our German
translations are significantly longer
broader than than the English ones for
example so so what one one good tip I
can give you here is to load up the
application Android studio and there we
actually have a view they can see all
the translations and all the languages
you have available in your application
they get a fantastic over you know the
same layout the same screen in different
in different languages so you can easily
spot the Texas cut off or doesn't quite
look right without having to click all
over the place it's a really really good
way to test it out yeah yeah definitely
so in localization make sure you just
give you test it out on you users
devices or in that users configuration
it's really really important often it's
it's not easy to necessarily have a
magic bullet for it sometimes you are
going to get text which is just really
long for your button and you need to
consider rephrasing that that button so
that you know text doesn't get truncated
or doesn't wrap and you end up with this
massive button so it is something that's
important but localization is probably
one of the best ways to grow your user
base because you're suddenly making your
app available to a halt to a whole group
of people that may not have otherwise
been able to consume that app or may not
have felt it was comfortable enough but
looks like we have a couple of questions
on us yeah from URI yuly Laguna so what
is the best way to have action overflow
button on devices with the menu buttons
such as s3 that's a that's a really good
question so yep they're still devices
that ship with menu buttons as well as
those that ship with virtual navigation
sort of virtual buttons rather and I
think to me this this is a bit of a
choice that you have as a developer you
could the action overflow typically what
would happen is that it would disappear
on the on the standard action bar and it
would show up as a menu I think that's
that's a that's a fine way of using it
because that's again if you think about
the consistency of the user experience
for people on that device they will be
used to using the menu button on the
other hand if you strip feel strongly
about having that that overflow there
something you can do there as well I I
don't think there's a right or wrong
here but more of a preference that you
can have and you know what with some of
these things depending on the app it can
also differ so there's no harm in sort
of doing some experiments you know
things like the staged rollout feature
that we've now enabled or alpha beta
testing channels on Google Play allow
you to actually experiment with a small
subset of users and see yeah you know
collect some analytics and see what's
working best I think you'll find that
again there's not just one right answer
for that sort of question yeah that's
right well I hope okay he said is it
okay in your opinion to have the
navigation drawer and sliding pane
layout even so that they both don't use
the same gestures it seems quite similar
yeah so that's that's always a problem
if you have touch interactions in your
application whether it's a it's a
sliding sliding pane layout or whether
it's a map or something so it's it's you
have to be desperate for trade off I'd
you have to make the right decision say
it can you accidentally trigger the
navigation role for example when you
actually want to slide your layout so
it's kind of the pencil application how
you have how use interact with it so in
in some ways overloading gesture it's
not a good idea yeah really wouldn't
recommend that it's especially something
you know like an edge smart folks and we
wouldn't wouldn't recommend that but
I've seen some applications where the
navigation drawer has actually been
quite successfully implemented med
actually goes on top of the rest of the
application so in this case of also a
map and you can pan a map but you can
still pull in the navigation drawer from
the side and that actually worked quite
well because was just triggered from the
edge yeah so the edge swipe or the the
bezel swipe that that that's become
quite popular I mean that's a sign of
time changing right because people are
users are getting more comfortable with
with bezel swipes across a full a whole
range of apps and even you know
platforms themselves so having those
bezel swipes there is not such a bad
thing particularly on Android that's why
we have that navigation drawer icon in
the top left in the action bar to show
that that we have this navigation drawer
available and they
you could expect that a bezel swipe
would bring it across so yeah you're
right when you said things like a map
where you've got content that you're
effectively panning around you would you
could think the world will a bezel swipe
trigger that the navigation drawer
should a pan the map if you're showing
visually that you have a navigation
drawer you're setting an expectation
with your user that you're going to have
a bezel swipe so consistency is probably
the most important thing so if you've
got that if you've got a visual
indicator have the bezel swipe there yep
okay all right well we're getting close
to the end of this but the the last two
things that I think we should really
cover are we we we already mentioned a
little bit about the the touch feedback
with the touch feedback often I see apps
that don't provide that feedback are the
ones that are using really custom-built
controls the reason I really wanted to
talk about this is I mean it's we
encourage users to have you know a
custom style a custom brand but it's
really important that you start with the
standard UI controls right and then
customize it rather than build it from
scratch because again with the standard
controls that you standard UI controls
you do get things like touch feedback
and it's not just visually it makes the
the if you if you use is enabled it also
makes that will audio click as well as
you interact with it and you just get
this this feeling sometimes it's
intangible that hey this is something
that feels familiar to me so whilst it's
it's great to sort of style your app
what you should do is be using our
styles and themes to do it or extending
our our standard UI controls rather than
building them from scratch you'll find
in general your your interaction is is
generally much more defined that way
inconsistent again yeah all right well
it looks like we're out of questions and
we're also out of time so thank you very
much for joining us we'll have two more
episodes of the dev bite series making
apps beautiful coming out
over the next couple of weeks and then
we'll be back for another backstage to
to answer your questions about the rest
of that series thanks for joining us
yeah thank you see you later